[Music]
this is good because i'm glad we're all
guys here because we're all gonna have
the same reaction yeah we're talking
about the sausage fest okay i bet you
i'm gonna blow your mind okay i hope you
don't choose
i hope you do because that'll be
interesting all right so a woman
suddenly loses her fiance to pneumonia
oh
good yeah he succumbs to he dies and
good for her now she's single i'm a
single lettuce oh
she's probably this probably high school
sweetheart she's been wanting to [ __ ]
throw her vagina all kinds of dudes but
she couldn't and now she'll find her
chances he's been holding her back do
you think that's true about all high
school sweethearts yeah like they're
they're ladies
she's wondering what the other dicks
feel like and she's looking at every guy
she doesn't know what another penis
feels like yeah oh my gosh she's always
gonna for the rest of her life think
about what but it only affects women the
closer they live to the rose bowl so i
think it's fine yes we're very good
there's something about the rose parade
and the rose bowl it's because of the
petal the flowering and the blossoming
of your your virginity like what's the
square mile radius like to the rose bowl
would you 600 i think yeah 600 miles
yeah i'm about like five that's intense
bro you're in single digit zone that's
like super get out
code red you need to move to phoenix i
didn't realize we're talking about you
so imagine this the woman the woman
loses her fiance
and uh right before he died they were um
in the process of um doing in vitro
fertilization
they were planning on it they were
planning on it so he had his sperm
frozen right they were planning on it
but now that he's dead
she can't have the kid because he forgot
to sign the consent form guys are the
worst because oh my god that's what i'm
sorry i shouldn't say forgot nobody it
was it just never came up the consent
form nah he's just a dude dudes are
[ __ ] dumb it never came up is it just
gonna be frozen forever yeah dude no
they already tossed it dude me and nicki
are in escrow she's like hey did you
sign that [ __ ] i'm like yeah
he just died he died
and then yeah
and then you know she checked my email
and she's like there it is he had stupid
[ __ ] and i'm like i could have sworn to
sign that too
that's just guys bro i feel like even
the smartest [ __ ] on earth does
the same [ __ ] now like i feel like you
could even have like the guy that you
think will never make any mistakes will
do the same [ __ ] the smartest guy in the
world
all you have to do is talk to their girl
to find out how dumb they really are no
matter what and how much she hates him
they think it might be the fault of the
company because they didn't
they didn't bring him the form
while he was still alive so it's their
fault this might be
a good thing for her though why
well because like
again she could get a lot of unpopular
opinion
but imagine right it's like she has his
child
that child for sure has to live knowing
that his deceased father and that and
then that child is also going to remind
her also it could be a lot of happiness
but technically she could also move on
have a child with a totally other
different person who doesn't have a dead
father you know what i mean and not be
reminded
i see your life is this you being
typically anthony where like is pat
tillman really a war hero though
you said that i did not [ __ ] say that
you said that
it's kind of [ __ ] up anthony
true man because she's guaranteeing a
fatherless child
and and the memory of that you know what
i mean versus like the possibility of
moving on yeah and then just like you
know new man new love new child that has
a father there like there could be
what you're saying single women can't do
a good job raising a child no i'm saying
that there's a by the way for the record
the careful boys we think single women
do just fine yep
i agree
i was raised by a single woman
and i terrorized her life i wish my mom
was single
because she she would have been happier
yeah she deserves what would you do i'm
just saying this is like an act of god
right this is like
whatever what would you do if that was
you and uh the consent form left
unsigned and you could come back as a
ghost to either do either one or the
other would you
would you sign it with your ghost hand
or just leave it as is it'd be hard to
say because if i came back and i was
about time i was like yeah she's about
to have my child and i look at her and
she's still like mourning me
i'm not i don't know there might be this
emotional like dude like
maybe you need to move on if you're a
true dude you would come back as a ghost
and then you're like
[ __ ] left my pen back over there
or you're like [ __ ] what did i come back
here to do i don't [ __ ] remember i go
i'm gonna go play mortal kombat
[Laughter]
i'll figure it out remember i think i
would want her to have my child because
that's the only way i could implant
myself into a human again
oh is this your quest to
is this your problem in our life is this
from the brain of a ghost or it's part
of just like a total hun thing got it
okay
obviously she wanted it so it'd be like
i would fully support that but because
now she can't have it it's like maybe
there's a silver lining is all i'm
saying i'm not saying one's better than
the other so here's the thing the reason
they were doing in vitro fertilization
to begin with is because while he was
sick um he was going to be going through
some treatment for i think cancer
and uh they froze the sperm because out
of fear that he might be sterile through
the treatments
so it was like for hey he's going
through cautionary i would want to
spread my seeds so they were already
gonna do it what's up dude like but by
law even though it's completely
undocumented that they had planned to do
this if the name isn't in that blank
they just can't who uses signatures
anymore yeah come on man unfortunately i
still had to yeah i was in escrow yeah
damn that's crazy
pretty shitty situation yeah but there
is a silver lining like anthony said but
you know what have you ever
been throwing a contract back at you and
then you're like that's not my signature
oh yeah
no joey
see what i think i should try that that
happened to you no i mean like
just even what i want to see what
happens when you deny a signature that
you sign oh and you're like that's a
forgery what are they gonna do they're
they're gonna be like let me see your
signature and you just do a different
signature sea judge it's a different
[ __ ] signal i think if it goes all
the way to the judge it's for sure gonna
be caught please don't send this video
to joe's future landlord he's trying to
get a house right now please don't send
this video to them
he's kidding yeah well when when this
when the when the when the contract
comes back um i just might try it
and say whose is this i've been frauded
i want to see what happens next when you
do that be like that's not mine and then
he loses his house opportunity he's like
oh okay i believe you
sorry this is your ip address that's not
my ip address
what if he just goes all right sign your
signature right next to this one and
we'll see if it looks the same are you
gonna [ __ ] your own thing up i'm gonna
change it yeah then you're not gonna get
the house yeah but at least i know the
process of a fraud is fraudulently
of a flaw you couldn't just ask him well
that's how you know he was kidding
landlord don't worry
hey level with me sir don't you you guys
never questioned yourself and said like
is this a binding contract because how
would they know it's my signature did
you ever forge your mom's signature for
like your grades all the time and my
teacher knew and i swear to god she was
wrong
and i think she didn't believe in god
and so then she was like
okay i don't believe you
she didn't yeah that's a big big should
have examined the situation better
should have noticed she believed so then
what happens then because they know it's
not your mom but i think a lot of time
they're just too [ __ ] lazy to verify
so they just go [ __ ] it yeah you know
what though i feel like the same thing
would happen here i uh i fraud myself so
i have two sets of signatures for the
big purchases and the legal documents
and the things that will bind me i have
a separate one
um and then when i go to the grocery
store where i go when i when they tell
me to sign for the [ __ ] like eat at a
restaurant or whatever yeah restaurant
yeah i got a different one because i
don't want some [ __ ] looking at my
signature and going oh that's easy right
and then they'll they'll forge my [ __ ]
okay but then they
you know i should have did the other way
around but then
very simple the the the the usual
purchases one i have such a complex
signature it eventually just became the
same one
but
the high security
like i'm buying assets this one is
simple which one do you do which one do
you do for fans it's my initial
which one do you do for fans when
they're like can you sign this for me
what do you do it's all the same now man
i got lazy oh autographs is completely
different
but then at the supermarket or [ __ ]
at a restaurant it's just a sperm so why
get not
let's do a sperm that's gonna continue
that's gonna confuse the verifiers of
the future when the merch is worth
millions so why get a barcode autograph
why why why bother because it's a
special one it's a special one it's not
it's not a fake signature it's still his
signature it's just for fans i still did
it technically
you know what i mean but they don't get
the sperm that the supermarket gets
okay haven't you guys ever heard of
stories where like uh
you know when when one of the parents
dies or something like that the other
parent ends up like leaving the child
because like every single time i see you
i see
you know what i mean that's a shitty
[ __ ] parent but you you have heard of
[ __ ] like that when the when the parents
uh
have a bad like breakup like this one
did this one dirty then they'll see it
and it's like i don't like you they
represent their kids it's not just oh
it's resentment usually versus never
really heard of like you're acting like
your mom right right like you're you're
you're you act like your mom that died
of cancer
yeah
yeah yeah yeah when you put it like that
it's usually like my [ __ ] mic
on me or whatever i've heard stories of
like where a parent
parents have lost their child and their
parents have split because of that yeah
like i've heard that i think i think
that's a lot more common yeah that is
different yeah like bart's one the best
standard
is the better oh you're just like your
mom that has cancer that passed away
last year
your kid gets cancer you get pissed off
at them oh my god dude yeah that's
pretty rough dude
it's high in divorce families though i
heard because they they see their ex's
face in the kid oh yeah and then so they
treat the kid all [ __ ] up and i'm like
damn dude i don't know i don't have no
kids i can't judge but right now you're
a piece of [ __ ] parrying me yeah
well i never got the thing where people
would be like you know if i uh
my daughter starts dating
like i'm gonna be pissed i'm like who
gives a [ __ ] and then i was like once i
fell in love and like nikki's my one i
was like dude if i have a kid and she
looks like nikki like when i met nikki
like like [ __ ]
and then some guys going after my chick
you know what i'm saying yeah that's a
different thing i'm like oh [ __ ]
let's go [ __ ] but now i get the the
sentiment i didn't get it before i feel
i feel bad if you guys have a daughter
and the boyfriend comes to
meet you you're going to [ __ ] give
him hell dude
i think she looks exactly like joe
i'ma
my daughter's boyfriend he did say he
was going to blow your [ __ ] mind
to find out if he's gay
so he knows what kind of family he's
getting himself involved in prove your
dominance yeah yeah
kiss you kawa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you